uh i can report as returning officer
that 359 ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favour
uh of having confidence in boris
johnson's theater was 211 votes and the
vote against was 148 votes
and therefore
i can announce that the parliamentary
party does have confidence
[Applause]
so
yeah well there you go that is the
results of the confidence motion the
cheers there the support
uh for the prime minister but just look
at those numbers do you have confidence
in boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party 211 mp said yes 148
mp said no that's a majority of just 63
and really in context that is quite
astonishing
133 was the number that he would have to
get
to do better than theresa may so that is
a lot worse than theresa may did in
percentage terms
and of course she resigned as leader in
the month after that confidence vote uh
people supporting at boris johnson were
saying they were hoping he would make it
to double figures so
get the rebellion under 100 mps well
that certainly hasn't happened
148 conservative mps and they don't have
confidence in the prime minister beth
well if you were in downing street
tonight looking at that figure you are
going to be disappointed by that that is
a very disappointing result for boris
johnson a majority of just 63
148 of his parliamentary party have
signaled that they do not have
confidence in him as prime minister that
is definitely on the upper end of
estimations that i had been hearing
today as i was saying earlier a vote of
over 100
knows
that is losing the majority of his
parliamentary party and the question
that comes from that vote is how on
earth can boris johnson really corralled
the party get legislation through
148 of his own backbenchers say that
they no longer have confidence in him
you only need 40 mps to consistently
vote against boris johnson for him to
lose his majority and there you have
148 that will give him plenty of food
for thought tonight i should say though
too sophie that the prime minister has
been very clear all of the way through
this as have his allies that he has no
intention of resigning
unless he is forced out of office but
that is
a deeply uncomfortable result for him
and you have to ask after that are we
now going to watch a period of time
where boris johnson is in office he
survives in downing street but he is not
really in power he does not have the
authority
over his party 148 of his own mps uh say
that they don't have confidence in him
you've got to remember that the
government payroll vote is 160-170
so you know he's bought in a lot of
support from the government payroll
there but 148 against him that is deeply
disappointing